so what was your experience on django
and and how did you end up in that
situation on that one
oh man i'm not even sure how much you
can say or not say
i i auditioned
a bunch of times for the lead in django
i was a complete unknown
um the part that kerry washington
eventually did brilliantly
um i was completely unknown i'd never
even i don't
i never really done a movie like like
not a big budget film
at all you know i did this taped
audition in new york and then the next
thing they were flying me
just to meet queen tarantino in l.a and
then he flew me to louisiana
and then um oh wait maybe it was the
other way around
anyway it he flew me places where i met
with him
um and auditioned with just him and his
casting uh vicki thomas his class
director
who's wonderful um and then
i didn't get the part which i weirdly
i was so excited to be auditioning for
quentin tarantine i was just like
whatever like you know i can't believe i
got as far as i got being someone who
was completely unknown and
all of those things and then um i had
read the script the script was
i'm not joking it was this thick i
remember
specifically this giant script
and i re the part i eventually shot was
not
in this giant script i almost feel like
and this is just me thinking that
quintero karen
gwen tarantino cares about me this much
i feel like he wrote me a part
after like flying me all over the place
because this thing didn't exist
right and then suddenly they sent me
this this um
it's what was a slave she's in the big
house and she has this interaction with
christoph walt and samuel l jackson's
like
you know the the big names she has this
very sort of funny interaction coming up
with steps
i did it i went to full again to new
orleans um
shot it uh with with sam and and
christophe watson
on this wonderful insane set i even ran
into carrie i kind of knew character
before but like i even ran into her we
had a
big chat and it was just so wonderful to
like be
in this thing i eventually got cut
i understand actually why i got cut
because
i think the scene that happens right
before my scene
my scene was repetitive for in terms of
the dynamics
what they were showing about the slaves
because my scene was all with it was um
sam jackson basically yelling at me but
he had kind of
just done that outside with carrie and i
do
feel like oh okay i think i would have
cut my scene too it's repetitive we just
saw him doing the same humiliating
yelling at
you know uh mocking
a woman outside and then he comes in and
he kind of does the same thing to me so
that's what happened this is the second
one
too but i don't even remember what my
slave name was this is the second
conversation i've had with someone who
got cut out of a big movie and
i just have so much respect for the way
that you both
look at it and just how you can
understand the big picture and not just
thinking of yourselves because like i'm
very sensitive about my work and i feel
like i probably wouldn't have handled it
that well
okay so here's the thing this was eight
years ago
maybe i don't know if i handled it
extremely well when i found that
i've had some time to reflect to be
mature about it
when i found out i was devastated
and i think at that point my husband and
now we do not do it
my husband had told everybody i was in
django unchained
and then they go to the movie theater
and i am not in django unchained so i
don't do that anymore i'm like do not
say
a word until i see the
final cut of this thing and know for
sure
that is understanding yeah it might be a
good lesson but yeah i don't know that i
was
super mature to begin with
you